- Luck is a process where you move
to luck and you take luck, and you say,
"Come on, luck, I keep you now."
So when you are free
man, when you have love,
when you have health, you
are again in paradise.
- He's the CEO of a
Swiss luxury watchmaker.
He was previously
successful in rejuvenating
the Blancpain and Omega brands,
which are currently owned by Swatch.
His leadership in the Swiss watch industry
has single handedly been credited
as saving the industry
from the quartz movement.
He's Jean-Claude Biver and here's my take
on his top 10 rules of success.
Rule number eight is my personal favorite,
and I'd like to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, as
you're watching the videos,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Also, as you are writing something down,
it's much more likely to
stick in your head too.
Enjoy.
(epic music)
- Love gives an energy.
With love, you go to the Everest.
If you don't have love, which
means passion for the business
passion is love, if
you don't have passion,
things are difficult to
achieve in life except normal.
Without passion, you are in the normality,
you are like everybody,
you are like a dead fish
in the road, that fish in the
road swims with the current.
And in the direction of the
current and in the speed
of the current, a fish that
is alive goes left, right,
against the current or with the current,
so without passion, you are dead fish.
If I tell you that we have 75 screws
and that each time the watchmaker
is finished going screw
and screw, then he should,
during 1/10th of a second,
when he's finished, I love my
job, then he goes next screw.
I love this job, the next
one, I love the customer
who's going to wear it, I love perfection,
if 75 times he's going
to say I love my job,
I love my customer, I love
my boss, I love my kids,
I love my wife, he will
leave 75 traces of love
in the watch and when
he shuts down the case,
the movement is inside, the
75 traces of love are there.
The universe of passion
is open to everybody,
but many people don't
know, they believe passion
should come down from the
sky, no, you go to find
your passion, passion
will not come to you.
Is like luck, luck cannot come to you,
you can buy as many lotto
things, you can make bets
on Barcelona and Madrid,
luck will never come to you
but you go to luck,
that's much more secure,
you go and go to take
luck, if you are in a state
luck comes down to you,
forget, you will die
and no luck will have ever
come, luck is a process
where you move to luck and you take luck
and you say, come on, luck, I keep you now
and you take another
one tomorrow and so on.
Today, especially in today's environment,
where we have so much competition,
where speed is so important, we need,
we definitely need to
always think different,
in my company, we have a very easy rule,
whatever we do, whatever, in any field,
we always try to be the
first and/or to be unique
and/or to be different, and
whatever the project is,
we have to put the three
conditions and project leader
or the guy who brings
the idea has to answer
those three questions, if he
says yes, we will be the first,
yes, we'll be unique,
yes, we'll be different,
it's finished, there is no budget anymore,
unlimited budget, no
restriction, he can go ahead
because whenever you are
the first and different
and unique, you cannot
be wrong, you will win.
- When you have downtime,
like if something didn't work
the way you want, what
do you do to get back
on that positiveness?
- I talk to the mountain,
I have a mountain
next to my home that is
called Rocher de Naye,
it goes up to two, it's very
low, it goes up to 2004,
2500 meters, or I talk to
the Dovey de Vie mountain,
which is 4000 mountains,
which is a little further away
from my home, which I see every morning,
I see those two mountains and
I say to these two mountains,
mountains, I have a problem,
but when I look at you
you are 37 million old.
(men laugh)
- And I am a little guy.
- You seem to be gay ...
- I am a little guy here
with a little problem,
can you help me, and they
will say, come on, look,
what we have already
seen in so many years,
your problem is a
nano-problem, come on, get up.
- Just get up, do it.
- And whatever, that's it.
Many people are what we
call managers, overseers,
and today they can spend seven
years in the watch business
and eventually then they
might move and be a CEO
in a car business or in a crystal brand,
you know, these people are
clever and great entrepreneurs
but they are not necessarily
deeply connected forever
to one passion, I am
connected just to watches.
I don't, I would never
like to do another job,
of course I have other little passions,
I love wine, I love cheese,
I love classic cars,
but I would never transform
them in a business
because my passion is not deep enough,
while watches is my
life, if I have to die,
I want people to remember two things,
I want children and my
wife to remember my love
and I want people to
remember my contribution
to the watch business, so
that's really my objective,
that's why I would never
leave this business,
and not many, I have been
in the business since '74,
so it's nearly 40 years, (laughs),
39 years in the same business,
and I don't know many people
in this business that
have been 39 years there.
Some great people came but
they came from a car brand
or came from Ferrari or
Maserati, and joined the watch
business and maybe in seven
years they're going to move
and go to Hermes or
Vuitton, so it's different,
I am a watch fan, a watch freak.
It's not enough if you get
help, you must accept help
and to accept help, you
must be capable of learning.
And who teach you how to learn, nobody,
the schools are giving you
every day a spoon of knowledge,
and you get it in, and
tomorrow another spoon,
and then you leave university,
but you don't know how
to learn because you have
been used that they feed you
with knowledge, but after the university,
then you have to start to
learn, you have to start
to learn how to learn
and you have to be humble
and you must never believe you know it,
you must have doubts,
the doubt is your friend,
anybody with little doubts, I'm afraid of
because these are the dangerous people,
people who drive the car
with no doubts in the fog
or on the street full
of snow, I am afraid of,
I want people that have full of doubts
because the doubt helps you to stay humble
and helps you every day to ask yourself
am I on the right track,
what I did yesterday,
is that right, my vision,
is my vision still okay,
and if you forget to ask
these questions daily,
one day, pfft, you will
be in the wrong direction.
So innovation, creativity
at the end of the day
is more powerful than knowledge.
Yeah, knowledge is so
easy for anybody to get,
of course you have to
study, you have to learn,
but knowledge is there whenever you want
with the new technology, whatever,
with all the universities,
knowledge is for everybody
here, and where is innovation,
where is creativity?
Innovation and creativity
is above knowledge,
that is what you put on top of knowledge
and thank God, innovation and creativity,
people normally cannot learn,
that gives a huge advantage
to the ones who are innovative,
if everybody could learn creativity,
if everybody could learn innovation,
we would have to invent
something more or different
to make the difference between the people
who have learned something and
the people who are innovative
so innovation, creativity
is definitely more powerful,
is much stronger, than knowledge,
creativity and innovation
is a way of thinking
and in order to make
people become innovative
we have created around in our company
an atmosphere that brings
people to be innovative,
and the most important atmosphere
is that you must permit
people to do mistakes.
If you give bonus for every mistake,
then people make mistakes,
but they make mistakes
with a huge pleasure because
they get an additional pay,
an additional money for every mistake
and when you ask people
to do a lot of mistakes
then people become very
active and they trust,
they start to trust
themselves, the problem is
in many companies, people
are afraid to be active,
they are afraid to take
initiatives, they are afraid
to innovate because
innovation brings uncertainty,
when you innovate, you
never know, innovation
is like vision, it's
not reality, the reality
you have to make it
through later and that,
to bring people, to take
risks, to be active,
you can only bring them to that stage
if you are capable of forgiving mistakes
and how can you show that
you forgive mistakes,
you give a little bonus for every mistake
and I promise you, if you do that,
little bonus, 100 to 1000
Swiss francs for a mistake,
if it's a very big mistake, a big bonus,
if it's a small mistake,
small bonus. (laughs)
So you see it's also a very innovative way
of bringing creativity out of everybody.
Hublot came out with a product in 1980,
a product that was based on an innovation
to introduce rubber as a strap,
it seems very common today,
but rubber in 1980 was
a real courageous move,
it was even the provocation,
people said hey,
on a gold watch, rubber?
Because people didn't know
rubber comes from a tree,
rubber is natural, rubber
is very comfortable,
it's very flexible and
rubber is very resistant
and it's waterproof so
finally it's ideal for a watch
but in those days, people
thought it's a provocation,
and then Hublot could
not evolve, they stayed
on a product and I said,
we are not a product,
we have a message first,
we have a concept,
and a concept is fusion,
why, because in 1980
when we put gold together with rubber,
we created a fusion
because gold and rubber
never come together, they were together
only one time in life,
during the Big Bang,
then everything was in one,
and then rubber went away
and said, okay, I go now on my tree
and gold said, okay, I go
and rest in South Africa
under the earth and
since then they never met
til people take them and connect them,
so I said Hublot made a
fusion and fusion must be
our message, must be our
philosophy, must be our religion
and once we have this religion
clear and it is named fusion
then we can develop further products
that not necessarily need rubber anymore
because fusion goes further
away than just rubber,
it can be carbon, it can
be ceramic, whatever,
so I was capable to free
Hublot from the product
and give Hublot a message
and from that message
new products were born and
that was the most important
element in the revival of the brand,
it's to take it away
from a product concept
and to give it a brand message
and from the brand message
we are then later born
in 2005 new products.
This guy from that company told me,
you going to work one year, Mr. Biver,
and I give you half a
salary, I said, what,
half a salary, 50%, I said, why,
I'm going to tell you, because
we not work during one year,
you will not work, you will
learn, and because you learn,
somebody must teach you,
and we, my company's going
to teach you, so you pay me
half of your salary to teach you
(laughs) These were the good bosses,
that's the right way to think,
that's what you have to tell
to the young people, you
come to me, during one year,
I give you a half salary
because the other half
you pay me because I teach
you, which is true, by the way,
that's how it is, but the young people,
they don't want half salary,
they want full salary,
okay, then I don't
employ you, stay outside,
go to another company,
young people must be ready
to accept half salary,
and they are not ready,
at least not in the few countries I know,
so this guy told me, half
salary and no office,
no secretary, no visit card,
no phone, no traveling,
no nothing, I said, what will I get,
you're going to learn, and to
learn you don't need an office
and to learn you don't need a secretary
and to learn you don't need a phone
and to learn you don't need a credit card
and to learn you don't need a name card,
so I started to learn, and in one year,
I was there learning, and how do you learn
when you go in a company,
they put you in an office
with the director of the
design and then you are there
and then you sit, and
the guy designs watches,
and he says, okay, hello, sit there,
and then you look, and the guy designs
and after two hours, you
say, what am I doing here,
I cannot look at this guy
designing all the time,
so you start to ask questions,
and then the guy said,
sorry, I have no time, I
must design my watches.
(laughs) Then you tell him,
do you want the coffee,
and he says, yes, and then
you go and make coffee.
(laughs) You start
becoming very, very humble
and you don't want to lose too much time
so you try to take from him,
to take knowledge from him
and then you tell him, yeah, for lunch,
can we have lunch together,
they say no, not now,
I have my wife, yeah, but maybe one day,
he says, okay, let's
see, and then you have
one day lunch with him,
and then the guy starts
to become more open, and one day, you say,
oh, can I invite you
with your wife to my home
and so I have been one day in the company
sitting with everybody, with
the director of production,
with the director of
the after-sales service,
with the director of quality control,
with the director of the design,
with the director of IT, with everybody,
with the finance, with
everybody and because of this,
I learn the basics of the
history of the company,
but also at the same time,
the history of the watchmaking
art and after one year, I
knew much, much, much more
about the history of
making watches, about how
to make watches, about the
mentality of the watchmakers,
about the history of the
Swiss watchmaking industry,
than anybody else because
I had been one year
just listening to people.
I had the passion as a
child, which was to play
with steam machines,
and one day I believed
that I should take the steam machine
and I should see how the steam machine
as an adult can be present, not anymore
like a steam machine but like a watch
so I made the transition
from the steam machine
to the watch, and then the
watch has become my toy
as an adult, toy of a
child, steam machine,
toy of the adult, the
watch, and from that day on,
I entered the watch industry,
and I was free of work,
I became a free man that
didn't have to work anymore,
so when you're a free
man, when you have love,
when you have health, pfft,
you are again in paradise,
so, I should call myself
paradise man. (laughs)
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
Joe Bordo asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave it
down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can
do, I'd also love to know
what did you take from Jean-Claude today
that had the biggest
impact on you, what message
hit you the hardest that you're
going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or
business, leave it down
in the comments below
and I'm going to join
in the discussion, I also
want to give a quick shout-out
to Janina Lee Del Rio,
thank you so much, Janina,
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
I really, really appreciate
all your support,
so thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
- I did a lot in my life, just
because I got a lot of help.
Help is all you need, and
help, how do you get help?
The first help is love,
love is all you need.
It's a song from the Beatles,
all you need is love,
and the day you die,
and you have given love,
and you have received love,
then that day you can say,
I was successful, that's
the only measure of success,
is how much love have I
given to other people,
that's the success and that's life,
we are here for a little
period, and during
this little period, we have one mission,
to share, sharing is an act of love,
try to share, try to think,
a mother shares her body
with all of you, nobody
here in this room is not
the result of a sharing
process between your mother
and yourself, if women would
refuse to share their body,
to share their blood,
to share their oxygen,
nobody would be born
anymore, so we are the result
of a sharing process, the result of love.
And that's the rule of life,
and that's all what matters.